mit m way jeden und alles wusste zur
braucht mit seiner familie abruf kanada
in der wildnis hat er die ultimative
lebensqualität gewicht
[Musik]
das lachen vergangen
dass ich überhaupt
[Musik]
jetzt garnicht familie schön wie die
jobsuche der hermann und sind motor
seiten sind immer unzertrennlich
menschen respektiert
schön sind die kanadier und ein mühe mit
dem schweizer des erzählens libertines
auf christine schönberg
[Musik]
sie begleitete stock schweizer
auswanderer auf ihrem weg in ein neues
leben
jedes jahr machen sich andere ich zum
glück im ausland
wien apa der us wanderer aus der ersten
staffel v die besucher und und
weitverbreitete sichtbar anfangen
populär
im westen kanadas what time atrium
hermann schönbächler familie
[Musik]
für sparta
daher muss ein gehäuse
ja ja ja ja ja letztlich sowohl nach
einer gegen die hinterachse und hat nie
aufgehört hat jetzt bin ich gespannt das
gerät keinen alles nur von bayernfan wir
viel viel andrea hennis abend ihre
familie zum beispiel für aber nicht
verfolgt die knapp ag alexandra jetzt
dogan
[Musik]
schon als die schönbächlers noch in der
schweiz wohnten arbeitete herrmann als
förster an weihnachtsmärkten verdiente
sich die familie ein zubrot mit ihren
kindern bücher und natascha wurden
herrmann und christine in biel in einer
engen wohnung jahrelang sparten sie so
viel sie konnten für ihren traum vom
leben in kanada anfang 2010 war es dann
soweit schönbächlers verlassen die
schweiz für immer
[Musik]
bewegungen
mitten im kanadischen wald hatten sie
ein haus für umgerechnet 250.000 franken
kaufen können sagt 9 hektaren umschwung
die lange reise war strapaziös und am
ende wartet ein unmöglicher desk altes
haus auf die kranke natascha
[Musik]
die familie macht sich vertraut mit
ihrer neuen umgebung mit sich
hermann beginnt seinen job als
angestellter bei einem wald pächter sein
neuer chef stellt im extra eine schwere
baumfäller aufgabe zum start die hermann
mit bravour meistert
[Musik]
job
schon als teenager träumte hermann
schönbächler von einem leben in der
wildnis von kanada auch frau christine
hegte lange denselben wunsch nun ist der
wirklichkeit
[Musik]
allerdings dass bothfeld mit der
euphorie von hermann nicht ganz mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
joachim m der kleinere ich muss sich
noch an seine neue heimat gewöhnen
sein vater ist bereits angekommen als
der sommer einzieht kommt der bart ab
[Musik]
schönbächlers wollen sich so bald als
möglich selbst versorgen
dank den fischreichen gewässern in der
umgebung brauchen sie nie mehr fisch zu
kaufen
wohl aber angler material auch wenn
hermann um jeden fischer haken kämpft im
herbst entdeckten sie weitere
kulinarische leckerbissen die sie gar
für gutes geld verkaufen können so ein
jahr nach der auswanderung dann die
frohe botschaft in rostrot die familie
schönbächler ist komplett alexandra hat
dem rest der familie etwas voraus sie
ist kanadische staatsbürgerin da sie
hier geboren wurde
die wirklich ganz gut im handwerk ist
was mir vorstelle bewegung nicht aus
papier vermehrte sich haye die die
fachleute
vor allem ist eine klare vision kann vom
leben im ausland wieder hermann und
seine familie
[Musik]
0 40 hermann immer noch so gern zu wie
eh und je
umso mehr will jetzt niemand stellt ist
sondern eigene rechnung schaffen
wie ist es eigentlich das unglück sie
wohin mit selbständigkeit browser
software hierfür genau wie die richtige
tier zwischen zwölf streifen schon mal
hierhin gebracht
[Musik]
die anderen nicht so mit der hermann
löns 1000 meter
zwar stehe hier dadurch die strecke
natürlich auch für war wusste verträgen
und so mache ich auch linear leopin
hermann immerhin fünf mal schweizer
meister im sportholzfällen hier vorkommt
als komischer und zu sorgen
das gibt's doch
danke danke
warum ich eigentlich zum umzug wie viel
mann eine pistole ja mit als eingespielt
das geht ganz weg zurück
irgendwann mal wenig mit dem
mannschaftsrat hat das wort heraus wir
sind froh für seine familie aus der
heimat an
das ist das wo jetzt für das ich einfach
eine und stinkt dem grund genau wo die
ganze wohl bahn in der generation zu
filmen am anderen ufer brachten frauen
hitze taxi hat nur einmal habe ein
fehler hat für sie wäre das für sie wird
die noch irgendwo der homo handwerkliche
kenntnisse aus ramacher im grundbuch
oder irgendwie erklärt bobo hat den
aggressiven mann mit tagen vier nämlich
vitus werk zum büros oder mit trainer
huber berge gibt also momente vormonat
denken wir die zeitungen vom konto hätte
also für burma womit sie nennt ein baum
im fußraum verwandelt
nur dass das ist moderne welt immer
weniger zählt zurückgeht schweizer
hermann a mix geringschätzig spürt
gegenüber 7 handwerk ganz anders kanada
hier recht respektiert mal im ball doch
wenn ich sage das ist ja richtig
der strom strom für uhr bekanntlich aus
durch aus der nicht qualifiziert ist man
habe das wichtige schritt werden
infanterist war die frau bereits genug
also da bist du in der hierarchie ganz
oben nur in der schweiz bestand habe
[Musik]
rost m brett wird zum die weiter sind
natascha und riechen vom schulbus
abholen
[Musik]
haben wir ja vorher an der rigi und
natascha längste schulweg vor allem
leute gegend an der park stand dort ein
weg mit dem bus die beiden schönen
brechen sind die erst übermorgen buche
stehen und die letzte wo wiederum
erinnert
hallo
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
kommt
[Musik]
temperaturen weit unter null
umso gemütlicher ist ihnen wissen wir ob
ich eigentlich immer grün doch schön
dass auch dich linie alexandra kennt
keine andere welt als jeder zweite
ihre schweizer zieht die chance oder 8
erreichen und sind eltern schwester
natascha weiter weg mit mir als kaspar
kathrin tieres schweizer unteren an
schweiz jetzt nämlich konsequent
englisch und das obwohl ihre eltern mit
ihm in schwyzerdütsch redet die
idealvorstellung linzer grünen und
wachsen so steht's im moment aber sie
lernen mit robotern abgeordneten auf die
anders
da die heime und eigentlich über die
ganze elektronik und so weiter und dann
sehen hier sagt seine sind aus dem
hochschul zu kaufen
computer sie kenne smartphones handelt
man das ipad ist ihnen unter hermann
sind nicht so ein event wie zu gotthelfs
[Musik]
die meisten schön weich hoch so ihrem
eigenes stück land mit mühes pendler bei
stress krass kürze der lebensqualität
thompson
[Musik]
alexandra ist der tag nur aus einzig die
high und christine stehe oder laden am
laufen halten ein riesiger gartenjahr
kleid und neu als jan o
später solle der kreis leader zug
erzählt sie mir eigene milch dass wir
noch einen schritt in richtung
selbstversorgung soli der
bewegungsradius so groß ist und wo nicht
wie das genau funktioniert
[Musik]
zwei bürger muss lena vor der bibliothek
gott wie scanner und nach einer woche
nicht auch wieder zurückbringen
[Musik]
ihre bank noch bis über die alte heimat
der schweiz klappt wie lange die schweiz
klappte halbjahr
in der pause spielt natascha als
einziges spiel mit dem namen
sie hat mit regler zu erklärt aber ich
bin ganz groß raus der bibliothekar in
[Musik]
roschwitz verarbeitete hermann sind
bäume zu brettern oder firmen und
private verkauft für den bau von
fassaden sitzplatz und autor unterstand
und ruß gewandert ist und denkt dass er
mal so viel holz wir sagen schuldigen
naturkatastrophe betroffen
der zehnte zehnte 2010 ist ein einfach
zu merken das datum und die familie
schönbächler wird es nie vergessen
ein unwetter zieht auf dass sich
unerwartet zu einem jahrhundert sturm
entwickelt der das leben auf ross und
nachhaltig verändert
mal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als der tag anbricht wird die ganze
zerstörung sichtbar
neben schlimm
der hockey club das tor des tages
das war hier das ist großer einzige
einzige
2 warum das das letzte nacht hermann
schönbächler wollte in diesem wald sein
meisterstück an nachhaltiger
waldwirtschaft abliefern
aus der traum
mit 44 machen sturm ist ewald neues bild
von probiotik musste luftdruck noch wir
näher am haus von der schönen sturm
gehört der familie als beschuldigter
dunkel aber ob sie darin
rosignano und im oktober nach verstummt
sind von dem platz vor der sturm aller
sauberkeit hat
das ist das ist ziemlich intensiv in
aktien des sturms gehörig wieder um 16
monate alte alexander wird strom
ja das ist schon das ist schon krass wie
nicht dass bei dem haus sind und wo wir
gehört haben wie bäumer wird aber
genauso das ist das angst macht weil der
sturm eine nur groß dass die frist auch
hegemann moment also heute noch eine
flüchten
nein das hat überall wohin und kinder
tasche unterricht und jedes zimmer gar
genauso wie herr overath wenn es an die
quere und die honico meeresbecken wie
sie sagen das ist der einzig sichere
orte und das bett liegen und und
offenbarte was hat das alles für ein
drittel der sturm
schlussendlich hat die zuständigkeit
braucht oder das einüben als
angestellter schafft sondern dass man
mit einem holz im grund musik ohne hand
und das hat zu unterstützen hat der
schotte ausgelöst dass man nach so viel
holz
brennholz verarbeitet hat nachher
angefangen mit dem saugen oder und ist
zum schluss ist es mir jetzt unglücks
oder fliegt also ist für euch los sein
zum glück im unglück
wie süd verarbeitet schönbächlers
zimmergroße bei stehen vor dem sturm
brenn und barcodes cruz und vor dem
mikro bleibt familie hauptsächlich
[Musik]
was wird ihre aufgabe nur da schon ich
mich wie zu hause
ja ich habe
irgendwie ist die ja hoffentlich im
finale sah nach bgh und der dem dir im
winter netz geistert die das erinnern
der netgear sind brüder und schwestern
und citroen xsara dbsh rosi und kartons
freizeit bbh betrat die und herrmann und
christine brennholz vor lauter für ihre
lieferungen
ich probiere mich nützlich zu machen das
brennen und verspricht ihnen das ist
dies zu verkaufen suchte die klassische
rollenverteilung hat drei kinder
hermann ist das also wähle richtung du
das hat sich so ergeben
ich habe das problem ich glaube ich
mache das gerne was macht dir also
zweimal los geht's zu den völlig andere
garn hier 2
also news gangs zweiter geld ja nie was
ich dass es nicht schon noch zwei drei
sachen das macht er sich nicht
ich bin noch nie im kino xiii darauf
vielleicht nein denn was wenn hier zwei
und drei war dass der gottesdienst
[Gelächter]
pastorin zurückgezogen
kaspar ja ja das label krük wir schon
bei so viel platz buch die hermann nicht
so einig sich mehrere tote christus
erklärt prof
da muss ich eigentlich mehr so viel
härter versteht doch jetzt nach holz bin
immer ganz sicher schön was in kanada
das ist kein mensch
ich stehe voll zwar wenig ruf aus ihrem
mann aber ohne ihre ruhige kraft im
hintergrund hätte der hermanns in
lebenstraum nieren umsetzen
[Musik]
selbst den spatzen die zu ostern hat
seine münchen mit gestern die das war
[Musik]
und nach
macht sich hübsch
sie gönnt jeder zweite sohn tick in der
evangelischen freikirche aberglaube ist
immer wichtig beide sind gläubige
familie groß wurde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im städtli terrors
die relation recht lucretia was
kleidervorschriften an gott
[Musik]
mit dörfer toni problemfilm eine von der
kirche verantwortliche witzelt sogar
schweizer fernsehsender vox wettbewerb
filme wie zum übrigen bad walter
herrmann also sogar kanada auf
[Musik]
in der zeit wo sich seele statt talent
fiel freilich abgeschiedenheit ein guter
nährboden für die glaube ziel
[Musik]
george schön dass du wieder gesund bist
wichtig zum freunde treffen
ok wenn du schweden und schweiz fahrt
aus aber verwechseln uns nicht mit
deutschland
bei bonn
mörlenbach
wir sagen dass ihr beide glaube beide er
gott hätte wenn gott da sag ich nicht
euro karte sie ruft kam der frost
glaubst also nicht nur glaubt ja ja ja
ich weiß nicht
die mehreren angefangen im grund
genommen absage mit dem zukauf aussagen
sind im grund genauer plan fragwürdig
sagte moritz gott hat die ganze erde
geschaffen oder tesco usa europa gott
und glauben dass gott besorgt
gott des plan hat familie schönbächler
of canada geführt in island wo der
schweiz doch sehr ähnlich aber mit einem
großen unterschied so viel mehr platz da
daher schön brach sogar ihre ganz
private initiativen zu erklären ist weit
und breit kein nachbar omo z doch nicht
nur kinder austoben darf richtig gas
[Musik]
also
das ist ja interessant hätte schon
frühzeitig die ihr welche gesetze so und
so muss auch irgendwo kvb linie bestehen
mit durchgeführt worden
das ist nicht viel aber wenn ich weiter
so denn irgendwann hoffentlich noch
weiter weg von der zivilisation
irgendwie schon
böser traum war das an sich schon mal so
richtig die welt müsse sie aber warnt
rinder oder und die können die tour und
also wie man es jetzt kein zimmer der
wildnis und zivilisation wird im moment
ist das ist es gut aber die matif traum
weiß vielleicht schon mal können
entwicklung ganz ganz nah bei dir ja und
das jetzt ist vielleicht auch linus es
lernen auf sonne city ja genau
wir haben sie richten was brauchts alles
und wenn das in der regel von uns
gegangen sondern solange es mir noch
hinterher im grundschulchor sie
unterstützung
dass wir vermehrt auch hier was der
filmreihe wünsche für die nächste kommt
dass man darum fällt ja dass forderungen
würde
[Musik]
familie hat ihren platz gefunden
wieder zurück in ihr zur debatte
gestanden
kurzum heinz de boer grix antrag stellt
zum anrufen papier kanadier werden im
herzen zieht sich schon längst
in einer woche wird wärmer in der
karibik stephansplatz und radio kann
real-trainer pro stark stellte und
lockerer bei bezirk innere große villa
mit ihren inseln braun
[Musik]
jetzt ist iris paradies bedroht die
große wirtschaftskrise gilt denn da für
grundnahrungsmittel und kriminalität
steigt aber nicht am morgen überfall
verdirbt eine weitere kleine
[Musik]
ziele die auf der suche
siegerin wurde
[Musik]
mit m way jedem sie bei und alles wusste
zu bruch
punkt ch